this is a puzzle for our viewers let's
see how quickly you can get it I'm gonna
start the timer now imagine choose you
can usually find by processor of
elimination is it zook's phone I'm
assuming it's not a check first of all a
minute down a minute down yeah usually
uh
time pressure no no I just wanna I just
wanna solve it I don't really care about
the time ah Queen A8
are you sure no but I mean once I saw
the move I thought it it's hard to be
yeah but Queen D4 takes away the D4
squares The Rook E3 is made otherwise
it's not D6 or Knight C5 is that it is
that your final answer
alone you got it in about less than two
minutes not bad
it's nice huh yeah it's really nice
it's actually it's actually typical of
these puzzles